ah
ew hey I'm Hayden Panettiere
wait hey I'm Hayden Panettiere this is
my ET retrospective we're gonna go
through some of my iconic moments my
brother told me to watch his chicken
nuggets for a minute so no one needs
them oh my gosh my my Wendy's commercial
this one was when Dave Thomas was
actually alive who ate my nuggets Thomas
I wanted to um
eat the Nuggets every take it's hard not
to tie one I wanted to stuff my face and
they had a spit bucket so they kept
having to come over to you sp for the
Nugget out spit the get out and I was
like look can I just do this one like
they were like trust me trust me
obviously they had done it a million
times before and kids had swallowed them
every time and then end up ended up
not feeling so well but afterwards after
the commercial was done then they let me
stuff my face
Guiding Light I remember the scene oh I
killed mommy's boyfriend I killed
monkey's boyfriend I shot him I had a
bigger the gun in me girl dead
daddy
that is admission to guilts right there
it's okay
[Music]
I learned how to cry
On Cue by my mom taught me how to how to
do it
[Music]
before crime scene I would go into the
corner and I would think of something
that made me really sad at at a smaller
age it was like you know my my uh pet
that just passed away like I would bring
the tears up up and then and then you
know hold them back hold them back hold
them back and and then wait till it was
it was time sometimes they'll play a sad
song in in my earpods do you have to go
a go-to sad song that you that you put
on the it's of course it's in the arms
of the Angels Sarah McLachlan
the arms
but I was doing it before the puppy
commercial I didn't do a car seat a
court seat there we go
oh my
God that was like I could see it
somebody asked me the other day if I
could curtsy and I said I don't think
I've ever curved seeds but that is not
true
dot you're a young queen ant and your
wings are too little to be talking to
mother you're not the queen yet Adam now
that be nice to your sister Hayden was
only eight years old when she voiced dot
in A Bug's Life that's the same age her
daughter Kaya is now she she has not
seen A Bug's Life yet I couldn't get her
to watch it because we were at um we
were stuck at Finding Nemo we were stuck
at fighting Nemo for a very long time
but thank God Moana
saved us
and and Moana happens to be one of my
favorite movies so I loved it but it was
every every day every day and then it
was on the on the on the eye on the
iPads it was uh in in America uh
Teletubbies and in in Ukrainian
[Music]
Remember the Titans this movie was my
favorite
movie to film the whole thing was so fun
it was just
almost the funnest thing that I've ever
worked on you have no idea how many
times in my life I have wished and
prayed if you know if I had a wish to go
back to any time in my life it would be
going back to Remember the Titans
hate playing with dolls I'm not playing
I'm accessorized hey why don't you go
accessorize don't you want to go
accessorize with
at the time I had no idea that
I was
working with Denzel Washington one of
the best actors of all time that Ryan
Gosling was going to become Ryan Gosling
that Kate Bosworth was going to become
who she became I mean there were so many
stars made made from this movie whenever
I see them I still expect them to treat
me like I'm the 10 year old like still
love on me like they did when I was 10
years old
first time I've seen I saw them like
after remember Titans I had grown up a
bit and the reaction was much different
it was much different and I was like so
confused and didn't understand why like
like why aren't you like picking me up
and throwing me around being like Oh my
God I love you and I had like matured
and it would have been inappropriate we
watched Hayden grow up on screen and on
red carpets bear back showing a little
skin
really
young that was like a like a 12 year old
version of like a Playboy bunny outfit
I'm
shocked that at my father obviously was
not
present
that was it was the day my dad was not
everything's gonna be okay
and then Helen but it's not
getting Helen
I'm the older sister I'm the I'm the
mean one does she mean in real life
look at Abby yeah Abigail is so young
Abigail Breslin I have known Abby and
Spencer reslin since they were even
smaller than this since before this we
grew up like auditioning together
Spencer actually did pulled a prank on
me we we shot that on Universal Studio a
lot and um and during lunch we went over
to the other side into Universal Studios
and we went and did the back draft and
when we got back to like to get back in
to go because lunch was over to go back
to work
um they were like where are your passes
and we were like we forgot them we're
sorry we're we we really are there and
Spencer was walking by and was expensive
Spencer tell them who we are tell them
who we are and he goes never seen him in
my life
walks off I could couldn't believe it
just walked off
they got me funny kid
Hayden revealed a hidden challenge for
her 2005 film Ice Princess
okay we're in definitely top four you're
going to the sections I got really good
at one point at the end like I really
got good I I
um I could do an actual spin
taught myself to do a spin I loved
skating backwards as fast as I could
um I I wish I I wish I had kept up that
um
that sport it's not one of those like
riding a bike where you can just put
uh you know the skates back on and oh
you can still do that triple Axel no you
have to stay on
on that every day but um but but it was
good at the time and I I had a lot of
fun
Bring It On All or Nothing
oh yeah gonna get a little crumpier
I've been asked to crumb and I I'm like
okay
um no I can't I I actually gotta go to
the bathroom right now sorry
but you don't make the rules
it's not our fault you couldn't bring it
women I love Rihanna I Love Rihanna I've
I've seen her over the years and and we
always say hello to each other and she's
she's always she's the best I just
bought a giant coffee table book of of
her so she's so she's being her bad self
in in my house too
yeah almost hold on Heroes
oh the first time you meet Claire
Bennett
oh my
oh my God almost I went up It's one oh
one shot I went up and when I got to the
top I dove out of the way and the stunt
double who was in the harness was the
one that that fell and I desperately
wanted to do my own stunt
um but I'm nobody got hurt but I'm glad
I didn't because the the harness broke
later that day and could have been bad
but it looks really cool the way they
did that see the Cheerleader Save the
World creepy whisper the future like
people who walked past
pictures
[Music]
I do have people scream at me to save
the Cheerleader Save the World in the
most random places then it's time for
your last chance question
[Music]
I memorized that like as soon as I got
the
the script I wanted to make sure I got
that right so that on the day I could
just
bang it out and they were shocked
that I I got it I got it right Wes was
shocked and I was like
Wes is happy with me
Wes Craven who invited you Trevor yeah
it was it was thrilling that that people
loved and fell in love with Kirby I was
I loved playing Kirby so I'm glad they
loved her as much as as much as I did
I don't usually have a lot of
expectations
in in life in this industry expectations
lead to disappointment so if you don't
have expectations you're never
disappointed you can always be
pleasantly surprised and and and happy
hey Mark
oh gosh pregnant me
on Nashville
think I gave them enough of a heads up I
just saw my whole stomach
my daughter was such a kicker and a
mover a rocker and a roller her whole
body I mean people would get so freaked
out because she would flip over not just
like a hand or input or anything like
her whole body would roll over our poor
DP Michael lohmann's usually sticking me
behind uh counter or a couch or making
me carry a purse that is far too large
for me oh yeah trying trying to hide the
pregnancy in the beginning I'm not I'm
not in one of the the models who you
can't tell is is pregnant
um until you look at them their belly
and then afterwards like can't tell they
were ever pregnant that is a nutmeg you
could see it it was written all over my
face she later confessed she had a hard
time with her characters postpartum
depression storyline because she
struggled with it too in real life
you're completely M.I.A for like three
days now you don't even want to hold
your dog I have a meeting okay and no I
don't have that postpartum whatever the
hell you call it crap my character was
going through a lot of of tough stuff
um and stuff that I could really relate
to
in my own life so acting it out on on
screen had its its moments
um
needed a little uh
difficult it hit home for some reason
when it when it hits so close to home
it's it's almost like it does the
opposite for the acting though it makes
you unable to
to connect with it like if you have to
be emotional
um but but it I mean I love the
performance scenes the performance
scenes like
who wouldn't love to pretend to be
a a musician a singer a rock star a
country music star
for
for a few years
I've thought about releasing my own
album Maybe maybe one day I will it's
not off the table
um but uh
we'll we'll see I I have a lot of things
that I want to do so we'll see which
which comes first can I help you
special agent Kirby rate FBI Scream Six
I was hoping that it was going to be
similar to Scream 4 and just the way
that
um that cast and crew became like family
we had so so so much fun the cast was
fantastic
um so supportive of each other
loved that Kirby came back
as the badass that she is we share a
certain history yeah
going through all the moments of my
career that I forgot was actually
um it was really really fun and really
funny and and nice to get a a different
perspective on myself at different ages
in in my life because you remember it
differently than and it happened
um but they're great memories fond
memories what's next for heat and
paneteer there there are things in the
works there are things in the works
um good things take time so
I will you'll be the
you will know when it's done laughs
[Music]